This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In the middle of a workday in April 2013, the Associated Press sent out a tweet breaking two explosions in the White House, it read. Barack Obama is injured. The tweet caused panic in the financial markets. Within minutes, the Dow plunged more than a hundred points as traders rushed to sell off stocks amid the threat of political instability. The news was bogus. There were no explosions, and the president was safe.
这里是《Hidden Brain》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2013年4月的一个工作日，美联社发布了一条推文，称白宫发生两起爆炸，推文写道：巴拉克·奥巴马受伤。这条推文在金融市场引发了恐慌。几分钟内，道琼斯指数暴跌超过一百点，交易员们在政治不稳定的威胁下纷纷抛售股票。这则新闻是虚假的。根本没有发生爆炸，总统也很安全。
The AP's Twitter account had been hacked. Within a few minutes, the information was corrected, and the markets recovered. When we think of misinformation, we often think of stories like this. Blatant cases of lies and falsehood, perpetrated by deceitful and malevolent agents. But in recent years, social scientists have found that misinformation comes in many flavors, most of which are far subtler than the erroneous AP story.
美联社的推特账号被黑了。几分钟后，信息得到了更正，市场也随之恢复。当我们想到错误信息时，通常会想到这样的故事。这是由欺诈和恶意行为者制造的公然谎言和虚假信息。但近年来，社会科学家发现错误信息有多种形式，其中大多数比美联社那则错误报道要微妙得多。
These forms of misinformation prey on our mental blind spots and take advantage of our passions and loyalties. This week on Hidden Brain, the many insidious forms of misinformation, and how we can all get better at separating fact from fiction. If you have a computer or a smartphone, you have answers. Want to know what year Abraham Lincoln was born? Look it up. Curious who invented the windsock? You can find out in 30 seconds.
这些形式的错误信息利用了我们的心理盲点，并利用了我们的激情和忠诚。本周的《Hidden Brain》将探讨错误信息的多种隐蔽形式，以及我们如何才能更好地分辨事实与虚构。如果你有一台电脑或智能手机，你就拥有了答案。想知道亚伯拉罕·林肯出生于哪一年吗？查一下就行。好奇是谁发明了风向袋？你可以在30秒内找到答案。
We have access to more information in a minute than our ancestors did in a lifetime. This privilege comes with a problem. How do we know if what we are seeing is true? All of us believe misinformation is something other people fall for. The uncle who gets his information from talk radio. Your high school classmate who trusts everything he sees on WhatsApp. The conspiracy theorist who imbibes lies on YouTube. At the London Business School, economist Alex Edmonds is interested in the science of misinformation. He says it's not just a fringe problem, misinformation is much more common than we think.
我们一分钟内能获取的信息比我们的祖先一生中获取的还要多。这种特权带来了一个问题。我们如何知道所看到的是否真实？我们所有人都认为错误信息是别人才会相信的东西。那个从谈话广播中获取信息的叔叔。那个在WhatsApp上对所见内容深信不疑的高中同学。那个在YouTube上沉迷于谎言的阴谋论者。在伦敦商学院，经济学家亚历克斯·埃德蒙兹对错误信息科学很感兴趣。他说这不仅仅是一个边缘问题，错误信息比我们想象的要普遍得多。
Alex Edmonds, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks Shankar, it's really great to be here. Alex, you live in the UK. Some years ago, the British home stores made the news. BHS, as it's called, is a massive department store chain that sold everything from furniture to clothing. What happened in 2016 to get BHS in the news, Alex? So it effectively went bankrupt. And when they went bankrupt, they had unfunded pension deficits. So former employees who were owed pensions did not get them paid. So companies go bankrupt all the time, businesses fail all the time, but this became something
亚历克斯·埃德蒙兹，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。亚历克斯，你住在英国。几年前，英国百货公司BHS上了新闻。BHS是一家大型百货连锁店，销售从家具到服装的各种商品。2016年发生了什么让BHS上了新闻，亚历克斯？它实际上破产了。当他们破产时，他们有未注资的养老金赤字。因此，那些被欠养老金的前员工没有拿到钱。公司破产是常有的事，企业倒闭也是常有的事，但这变成了一桩丑闻。
of a scandal, Alex. Can you explain why? What happened here that was not just a business going out of business, but something that felt like malfeasance was at play? Certainly you're absolutely right that just being bankrupt, that is just what business is. That's the nature of the beast. But here what happened was the former owner, Sir Philip Green, who was a rather larger than life character, he took out a lot of money and huge dividends to himself. And then he sold this company to a guy called Dominic Chappelle, who was a formerly bankrupt entrepreneur. He'd bankrupt further businesses in the past. And so by selling to him, he just put this in jeopardy and didn't care about all of the
亚历克斯，你能解释一下为什么吗？这里发生的事情不仅仅是一家企业倒闭，而是让人感觉存在渎职行为？当然，你说得完全正确，破产只是商业的一部分。这就是商业的本质。但这里发生的事情是，前所有者菲利普·格林爵士，一个相当张扬的人物，他为自己提取了大量资金和巨额股息。然后他把这家公司卖给了一个叫多米尼克·查佩尔的人，他以前是个破产的企业家。他过去曾让其他企业破产。所以通过卖给他，他只是把公司置于危险之中，根本不在乎所有的
employees. So, Alex, Philip Green sells BHS to Dominic Chapelle. Thousands of people lose their jobs. Many more go without their full pensions. News outlets, meanwhile, report that Philip Green is awaiting delivery of a $150 million super yacht named Lionheart. Meanwhile, reports report that Philip Green is awaiting delivery of a $150 million superyacht named Lionheart. I'm imagining all this does not endear him to the British public. Yeah, that's correct. So again, the fact that a company goes bankrupt, that is part and parcel
员工。所以，亚历克斯，菲利普·格林把BHS卖给了多米尼克·查佩尔。成千上万的人失去了工作。更多的人拿不到全额养老金。与此同时，新闻媒体报道称，菲利普·格林正在等待交付一艘价值1.5亿美元、名为“狮心号”的超级游艇。与此同时，报道称菲利普·格林正在等待交付一艘价值1.5亿美元、名为“狮心号”的超级游艇。我想这一切并不会让他赢得英国公众的好感。是的，没错。所以再说一次，公司破产是商业的一部分。
of business. But if the company goes bankrupt and former employees don't have their pensions, and yet there's the person who's got a huge show of extravagance, this is a big problem. and yet there's the person who's got a huge show of extravagance, this is a big problem. So around the same time as the BHS candle, another UK chain, Sports Direct, faced its own set of controversies. Do you remember what happened, Alex? Yeah, so here we had a similar situation with a rather larger-than-life character. So the chairman is a guy called Mike Ashley, who also owned Newcastle United Football Club and therefore was very much in the public eye. But Sports Direct was under pressure for a number of reasons and one of them was not paying the minimum wage and that
但如果公司破产了，前员工拿不到养老金，而那个人却在炫耀奢侈，这就是一个大问题。而那个人却在炫耀奢侈，这就是一个大问题。大约在BHS丑闻发生的同时，另一家英国连锁店Sports Direct也面临着一系列争议。你还记得发生了什么吗，亚历克斯？是的，这里的情况与那个相当张扬的人物类似。董事长是一个叫迈克·阿什利的人，他也拥有纽卡斯尔联足球俱乐部，因此非常受公众关注。但Sports Direct因多种原因受到压力，其中之一就是不支付最低工资，而这
was just one of many bad workplace practices. So these scandals prompted a parliamentary hearing and you were summoned to testify in front of the select committee on business. Now, you've been long interested in corporate governance, executive pay, making a case for responsible business practices. Was this why you were called to testify, Alex? You're absolutely right, Shankar. This is in my field.
只是众多恶劣工作习惯中的一个。因此，这些丑闻引发了议会听证会，你被传唤到商业特别委员会作证。你长期以来一直对公司治理、高管薪酬以及倡导负责任的商业实践感兴趣。这就是你被传唤作证的原因吗，亚历克斯？你说得完全正确，尚卡尔。这正是我的领域。
This is in my strike zone. I'm an academic, but I'm really passionate about using academic research for practical purposes so I submitted some written evidence to the inquiry. And based on the quality of the evidence submissions, the select committee then calls some witnesses to testify orally in order to delve deeper in the questions that they're trying to address. So as you were listening to another witness, you heard something that caught your attention. Tell me what it was, Alex.
这正是我的专长。我是一名学者，但我非常热衷于将学术研究用于实际目的，所以我向调查组提交了一些书面证据。根据证据提交的质量，特别委员会随后传唤了一些证人进行口头作证，以便深入探讨他们试图解决的问题。当你听另一位证人作证时，你听到了引起你注意的事情。告诉我那是什么，亚历克斯。
Yeah, so I got in early, perhaps because I was nervous. I needed to swat up on everything I'd written in my testimony just to make sure that if they asked me any questions that I was prepared. But I still listened with one ear open to what was happening. And there was a witness, the Trades Union's Congress, and what they mentioned was some research which sounded really noteworthy.
是的，我到得很早，也许是因为我太紧张了。我需要温习我在证词中写的一切，以确保如果他们问我任何问题，我都做好了准备。但我仍然留心听着正在发生的事情。有一位来自工会大会的证人，他们提到了一些听起来非常值得注意的研究。
They said, the lower the pay gap between the CEO and the average employee, the better the company performance. And why did my ears prick up when I heard this? Because this was something I really wanted to be true. It shined with my views on responsible business. As I just discussed, in many cases, the more responsibly you act towards wider society and your employees, the better the company performance. So this seemed to be music to my ears.
他们说，首席执行官与普通员工之间的薪酬差距越小，公司业绩就越好。为什么我听到这个时竖起了耳朵？因为这是我真心希望是真的事情。它与我对负责任商业的看法相吻合。正如我刚才讨论的那样，在许多情况下，你对更广泛的社会和员工表现得越负责任，公司业绩就越好。所以这听起来像是天籁之音。
So you were happy to hear about this research that suggested that the narrower the pay gap between the CEO and the average worker, the better the company did. What prompted you then to do the next step of actually looking up the origins of this claim? I'd say it was entirely selfish. So I thought this was a great study. I would like to quote this study. So I wasn't coming out to try and check this or to catch anybody out, but I thought great
所以你很高兴听到这项研究，它表明首席执行官与普通员工之间的薪酬差距越小，公司业绩就越好。那么是什么促使你采取下一步行动，去查证这一说法的来源呢？我想这完全是出于私心。我觉得这是一项很棒的研究。我想引用这项研究。所以我并不是要查证它或抓住谁的把柄，但我心想，太棒了
study let me know what the study is. So the next time that I am to talk to companies about the importance of responsibility, I have another weapon in my arsenal. And so, well, how did I look this up? Well, the witness had, like me, submitted some written evidence beforehand. So I went to the written evidence and I found the paper that they cited. And then I looked up the paper on my iPad and then the paper seemed to say completely the opposite. Actually the greater the gap between CEO and Worker Pay, the better the company performance.
这项研究，让我看看这项研究是什么。这样下次我和公司谈论责任的重要性时，我就有了另一个武器。那么，我是怎么查到的呢？好吧，那位证人像我一样，事先提交了一些书面证据。所以我去了书面证据那里，找到了他们引用的论文。然后我在iPad上查了那篇论文，结果论文似乎说了完全相反的话。实际上，首席执行官与员工薪酬之间的差距越大，公司业绩就越好。
I was confused. I thought maybe because I was so nervous because of my own session, did I misread everything? Perhaps because academic papers are not known for their clarity. But no, it was there. As clear as day, the greater the pay gap, the better the company performance. What do you think happened? Did they actually just misread the paper? So that would be one interpretation is that they just misquoted it but actually it wasn't as bad as that. What I noticed was I was looking at the 2013 version of the paper but what they quoted in their written
我很困惑。我想也许是因为我太紧张了，因为我自己的环节，我是否读错了所有内容？也许是因为学术论文并不以清晰著称。但不，它就在那里。清清楚楚，薪酬差距越大，公司业绩越好。你认为发生了什么？他们真的只是读错了论文吗？这是一种解释，即他们只是引用错了，但实际上并没有那么糟糕。我注意到我查看的是2013年版本的论文，但他们在书面
evidence was the 2010 version of the paper and when I looked up the 2010 version of the paper it indeed had the opposite result, the one they originally quoted. So what had changed between 2010 and 2013 was the manuscript had gone through peer review, where the peer review process forces the authors to correct any mistakes. Once they corrected their mistakes they found completely the opposite result. Once they corrected their mistakes, they found completely the opposite result. Notice that the inquiry was in 2016. So the 2013 paper was already out there for three years. Well, of course, it could have just been an oversight.
证据中引用的是2010年版本的论文，当我查阅2010年版本的论文时，它确实得出了相反的结果，即他们最初引用的那个。所以2010年到2013年之间发生的变化是，手稿经过了同行评审，同行评审过程迫使作者纠正了任何错误。一旦他们纠正了错误，他们就发现了完全相反的结果。一旦他们纠正了错误，他们就发现了完全相反的结果。请注意，调查是在2016年进行的。所以2013年的论文已经发表三年了。好吧，当然，这可能只是一个疏忽。
They happened to come by the 2010 paper. They didn't realize the 2013 paper was out there. You finished your testimony. It went well, but you decided that you were going to try and correct the record and help the committee basically get the correct paper. And so you went up to them afterwards and told them about the 2013 paper. How did you do this? What happened? Yes, so there's a clerk to the select committee who's not a member of Parliament but a senior civil servant, and he I was quite cordial with because he was the person I'd interacted with in terms of inviting me
他们碰巧看到了2010年的论文。他们没有意识到2013年的论文已经发表了。你完成了你的证词。进展顺利，但你决定尝试纠正记录，并帮助委员会基本上获得正确的论文。所以你事后找到他们，告诉了他们2013年的论文。你是怎么做的？发生了什么？是的，特别委员会有一位职员，他不是国会议员，而是一位高级公务员，我和他相当友好，因为他是我在受邀
to testify. And I mentioned this and he seemed horrified. He's deemed this was really bad. Even if it was an honest mistake, he wanted to make sure that this inquiry conducted by the UK government had the best evidence. And he invited me to submit a supplement to my initial written evidence, responding to what I'd heard in the earlier session, I did so and the committee published it. So that's very promising. Is that how the committee eventually ended up its conclusions or does the story go further
作证时与之互动的人。我提到了这一点，他似乎感到震惊。他认为这真的很糟糕。即使这是一个诚实的错误，他也想确保英国政府进行的这项调查拥有最好的证据。他邀请我提交一份对我最初书面证据的补充，回应我在早些时候的会议中听到的内容，我照做了，委员会也发表了它。所以这非常有希望。委员会最终是这样得出结论的吗，还是故事还有后续
than this? Unfortunately not. There is a twist. So even though the committee published my supplementary evidence, which suggests they endorsed that what I'd written, the final report of the inquiry, which was made after considering all the written submissions and also the oral evidence in the hearings, still referred to the overturned result as if it was gospel, the idea that lower pay gaps lead to better company performance, and this led to them recommending that all companies disclose their pay gaps, and that
比这更复杂？不幸的是没有。有一个转折。尽管委员会发表了我的补充证据，这表明他们认可了我所写的内容，但调查的最终报告是在考虑了所有书面提交和听证会上的口头证据后做出的，仍然把那个被推翻的结果当作金科玉律，即薪酬差距越小导致公司业绩越好的观点，这导致他们建议所有公司披露其薪酬差距，而该
recommendation eventually did become law. So this was something with some actual consequences. And in some ways, I think I can understand how this came about. This is coming on the heels of these major scandals where you have these leaders of these companies behaving in ways that are, you know, if not unethical then clearly perhaps improper. Certainly it didn't pass the the seamliness test, if you will. A lot of people lost their jobs, a lot of people had their pension benefits reduced, politicians got involved, Parliament got upset, and they wanted to hear the story that basically
建议最终成为了法律。所以这是一件有实际后果的事情。在某种程度上，我想我能理解这是怎么发生的。这是在这些重大丑闻之后发生的，这些公司的领导者表现出的行为，你知道，如果不是不道德，那显然也许是不恰当的。当然，它经不起体面测试。很多人失去了工作，很多人的养老金福利减少了，政客们介入了，议会感到不安，他们想听到一个故事，基本上
said, you know, you really need to rein in CEO behavior. And so in some ways, a study that basically said smaller pay gaps between the CEO and the median worker seem like it fit that larger thesis. Do you think that's how it came about, that that's what the driving impetus was for this error to persist in the final report? I do think so. So I don't think the committee set to deliberately misrepresent the evidence. I think that why did they start the inquiry? They did believe that CEOs were overpaid and they think that overpayment is a bad thing,
说，你知道，你真的需要控制首席执行官的行为。所以从某种程度上说，一项基本上说首席执行官与中位数员工之间薪酬差距较小的研究，似乎符合那个更大的论点。你认为这就是它的由来吗，这就是导致这个错误在最终报告中持续存在的驱动力吗？我确实这么认为。所以我不认为委员会故意歪曲证据。我认为他们为什么要开始调查？他们确实相信首席执行官薪酬过高，而且他们认为薪酬过高是一件坏事，
that indeed was potentially a contributor to the two scandals of BHS and Sports Direct. Therefore, any evidence that they saw, they interpreted to be supportive of this. And if there was evidence against that, they might have dismissed that evidence because it just didn't sound right, it didn't feel right and so they responded to the evidence selectively. When we come back the psychological drivers of misinformation. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. There are reams of psychological research on the power of stories.
这确实可能是BHS和Sports Direct两起丑闻的促成因素。因此，他们看到的任何证据，他们都将其解释为支持这一点。如果有什么证据反对这一点，他们可能会驳回该证据，因为它听起来不对，感觉不对，所以他们有选择地回应了证据。当我们回来时，将探讨错误信息的心理驱动因素。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。关于故事的力量，有大量的心理学研究。
A compelling emotional narrative can capture our attention and persuade us in ways that data and reasoning often cannot. But what happens when our feelings are contradicted by the facts? Economist Alex Edmonds has spent years immersed in the world of data, science and math. He's found that there are psychological forces that make misinformation hard to fight. Alex, you were once cleaning up your junk email folder when you came across a message that stopped you in your tracks. What was this message?
一个引人入胜的情感叙事可以抓住我们的注意力，并以数据和推理往往无法做到的方式说服我们。但是，当我们的感受与事实相矛盾时会发生什么？经济学家亚历克斯·埃德蒙兹多年来一直沉浸在数据、科学和数学的世界中。他发现，有一些心理力量使得错误信息难以对抗。亚历克斯，你曾经在清理垃圾邮件文件夹时，看到了一条让你停下脚步的信息。那条信息是什么？
So this was a message from one of the leading investors in the world. So I'll call this investor Xinyi. So Xinyi had heard about my research showing that companies with high employee satisfaction beat their peers in terms of total shareholder return over a 28-year period. And she was interested in launching a fund based not in employee satisfaction but gender diversity and wondered if I could do a similar study showing app performance of more diverse companies.
这是一条来自世界领先投资者之一的信息。所以我称这位投资者为欣怡。欣怡听说过我的研究，该研究表明，在28年的时间里，员工满意度高的公司在总股东回报方面超过了同行。她有兴趣发起一只基金，不是基于员工满意度，而是基于性别多样性，并想知道我是否能做一项类似的研究，展示更多样化公司的表现。
So in the earlier work that you had done, Alex, you had examined the hundred best companies in America and looked at sort of what might be driving their success. And you found this correlation between employee satisfaction and company success. Did you find that employee satisfaction was the driver of company performance or just that the two things were correlated? This is really important because as we know correlation does not imply causation and we need to be particularly careful when there's a danger of confirmation bias. We'd love to believe that there's good karma in the world, that companies that treat their
在亚历克斯你之前所做的工作中，你检查了美国最好的100家公司，并观察了是什么在推动它们的成功。你发现了员工满意度与公司成功之间的这种相关性。你发现员工满意度是公司业绩的驱动力，还是仅仅发现这两件事相关？这真的很重要，因为我们知道相关性并不意味着因果关系，当存在确认偏误的危险时，我们需要特别小心。我们很乐意相信世界上有好的因果报应，那些对待
workers better do better in the long term, but it could be the opposite. It could be that once a company starts doing well, then it can start investing in its employees. Or maybe there's causality in neither direction. There's a third factor that affects both. So maybe a great manager makes her employees happy because she's a great leader, and a great manager makes some good strategic decisions, and that leads to better company performance. So a lot of a job of an academic is to make sure that we really nail a result. In order to get published in a top scientific journal, we need to address those alternative explanations,
员工更好的公司在长期内表现更好，但这可能是相反的。可能是公司开始做得好之后，才能开始投资于员工。或者也许因果关系在两个方向上都不存在。有第三个因素同时影响两者。所以也许一位伟大的经理让她的员工快乐，因为她是一位伟大的领导者，而一位伟大的经理做出了一些好的战略决策，这导致了更好的公司业绩。所以学者的很多工作是确保我们真正确定一个结果。为了在顶级科学期刊上发表文章，我们需要解决那些替代解释，
and that's all the blood and sweat and tears that I had to shed in order to get this paper published. Alex agreed to meet the famous investor. She invited him to the Dorchester Hotel in Park Lane, London. If you play Monopoly, the most expensive square on the Monopoly board is Mayfair. The second most is Park Lane. So this is really real estate. And so Park Lane is a road which overlooks Hyde Park, a huge, beautiful park in London.
这就是我为了发表这篇论文所付出的血汗和泪水。亚历克斯同意会见这位著名的投资者。她邀请他去伦敦公园巷的多切斯特酒店。如果你玩大富翁，大富翁棋盘上最贵的方格是梅菲尔。第二贵的是公园巷。所以这真的是房地产。公园巷是一条俯瞰海德公园的道路，海德公园是伦敦一个巨大而美丽的公园。
And the Dorchester Hotel was a plush hotel. I think right now it would cost £800 per night to stay there. So the lobby had high ceilings, it had big windows, lots of light was flowing through. So it looked to be a beautiful hotel, the sort of hotel that one of the leading investors in the world would be staying at. So what did Shunyi want? So she mentioned that she was potentially going to be launching this new fund based on gender diversity. And she heard of my prior study. So she first asked whether I could directly tell her whether that study already showed that diversity led to outperformance.
多切斯特酒店是一家豪华酒店。我想现在住那里每晚要花费800英镑。大堂天花板很高，有大窗户，光线充足。所以它看起来是一家美丽的酒店，那种世界领先投资者会住的酒店。那么欣怡想要什么？她提到她可能要发起这只基于性别多样性的新基金。她听说过我之前的研究。所以她首先问我是否能直接告诉她那项研究是否已经表明多样性导致了超额表现。
And I said no, because employee satisfaction covers many things, not just diversity, but things like fair pay, credibility, respect, fairness, pride and camaraderie. So she said, well, could I not adapt my methodology and rather than looking at employee satisfaction, look at diversity as being the driver? And I said, yeah, potentially. And indeed, there's a lot of measures out there of diversity that we can look at. It could be diversity in the boardroom, diversity in the work, the workforce. It could be winning a working mother or similar award.
我说不，因为员工满意度涵盖了很多事情，不仅仅是多样性，还有公平薪酬、可信度、尊重、公平、自豪感和同志情谊等事情。所以她说，好吧，我能不能调整我的方法，而不是看员工满意度，而是看多样性作为驱动力？我说，是的，有可能。事实上，有很多关于多样性的衡量标准我们可以查看。它可以是董事会的多样性，工作场所的多样性，员工队伍的多样性。它可以是赢得“职场母亲”或类似奖项。
It could be the number of gender controversies in the news. And so you decided to take on this study. What did you think was exciting about the idea? What did you think that you would get out of it? It was the potential to partner with her in the launch of this fund. So clearly it was a preliminary discussion. We didn't discuss any terms or anything,
它可以是新闻中性别争议的数量。所以你决定进行这项研究。你认为这个想法有什么令人兴奋的地方？你认为你会从中得到什么？这是与她合作发起这只基金的潜力。显然这是一个初步讨论。我们没有讨论任何条款或类似的事情，
but the reason for the meeting was implicitly that I could help her launch the fund. And this would have been amazing for my career. So not only might this be good financially, but I would be catapulted in to the mainstream from the academic backwaters in which I was used to working in, and also it's something I cared about intrinsically. So as an ethnic minority, I believe diversity be very important and if indeed you could launch a fund which does well for society in terms of promotion of females, if this led to higher financial returns, that would be a win-win. And that would be good for me intrinsically in addition to the instrumental benefits of
但会议的原因隐含着我可以帮助她发起这只基金。这对我的职业生涯来说将是惊人的。所以这不仅在经济上可能很好，而且我会被从我习惯工作的学术死水推向主流，而且这也是我内在关心的事情。作为一个少数族裔，我相信多样性非常重要，如果确实可以发起一只在促进女性方面对社会有益的基金，如果这导致了更高的财务回报，那将是双赢。这对我来说，除了
financial returns and also perhaps greater recognition. So what did you do? Did you launch such a study, Alex? I did. I did do that study and there were 24 different measures of female friendliness available and so I worked with one of my MBA students at Wharton who was somebody who was a stellar student who got an A plus in my class. He had also told me that he was really interested in ethical business. So we worked together correlating these 24 different measures of performance with long-term financial returns. And what did you find?
财务回报和也许更大的认可等工具性好处之外，在内在方面也是有益的。那么你做了什么？你发起了这样一项研究吗，亚历克斯？我做了。我确实做了那项研究，有24种不同的女性友好衡量标准可用，所以我与我在沃顿商学院的一名MBA学生合作，他是一位出色的学生，在我的课上得了A+。他还告诉我，他真的对道德商业感兴趣。所以我们一起将这24种不同的绩效衡量标准与长期财务回报进行了相关性分析。你发现了什么？
So unfortunately, we did not find what we hoped to find. So the vast majority of these measures found a negative relationship with long-term shirhold returns. There were only two measures which found a positive relationship. One of them was insignificant. So what that means is that the increase in returns was so small that it could have been due to luck rather than gender equality. But there was one result where there was a significant relationship between female friendliness and long-term shelter returns. So what did you do? What did you go back and tell the investor who
不幸的是，我们没有发现我们希望找到的结果。绝大多数这些衡量标准发现与长期股东回报呈负相关。只有两个衡量标准发现了正相关关系。其中一个是微不足道的。所以这意味着回报的增加太小了，以至于可能是由于运气而不是性别平等。但有一个结果显示女性友好与长期股东回报之间存在显著关系。那么你做了什么？你回去告诉那位要求进行这项研究的投资者了吗？
had asked for the study? What did you report? Well, what we should have done was just report the two ones that were successful. And that would have been great because then I might have partnered with her in the launch of this fund, but that would not be correct. So my job is a researcher and as a researcher, you can't just bury some results because they don't support what you'd like to find. So we reported all of the results, including the huge number, which unfortunately found no relationship or a negative relationship. And we sent this to Shin Yi.
你报告了什么？好吧，我们应该做的只是报告那两个成功的结果。那会很棒，因为那样我可能就会与她合作发起这只基金，但这不正确。所以我的工作是研究人员，作为研究人员，你不能仅仅因为结果不支持你想要找到的东西就掩盖它们。所以我们报告了所有的结果，包括那些不幸发现没有关系或负相关的大量结果。我们把这些发给了欣怡。
Did Shin Yi accept the results? What was her reaction? She seemed disappointed but she seemed to accept that this is just what the results were. She thanked me and then that was the end of the project. Was this the end of the story though? It unfortunately was not. So a few months later I saw a press release where Xin Yu was launching a new fund based on gender diversity and this was the very thesis that she'd asked me to study. And this was surprising because in the press release announcement it said that there was a strong relationship between gender diversity and long-term financial performance, which was the very thesis that I had found not to be true.
欣怡接受了这些结果吗？她的反应是什么？她看起来很失望，但她似乎接受了这就是结果。她感谢了我，然后项目就结束了。但这是故事的结局吗？不幸的是不是。几个月后，我看到了一份新闻稿，欣怡正在发起一只基于性别多样性的新基金，这正是她让我研究的论点。这令人惊讶，因为在新闻稿公告中说，性别多样性与长期财务表现之间存在很强的关系，这正是我的研究发现并非如此的论点。
So my results overall did not support it, but what she did find was some study done by a commercial company which suggested there was a positive link between gender and financial performance. financial performance. You call this idea data mining and you say that both researchers as well as advocacy organizations are sometimes guilty of this. Can you explain what data mining is? Yeah, so data mining is that you start with a preferred result that you want to find and then you mine the data.
所以我的结果总体上不支持它，但她发现的是一家商业公司所做的一些研究，表明性别与财务表现之间存在正相关联系。你称这个想法为数据挖掘，你说研究人员和倡导组织有时都会犯这种错误。你能解释一下什么是数据挖掘吗？是的，数据挖掘就是你从一个你想要找到的首选结果开始，然后你挖掘数据。
You run the data in so many different ways until you get a positive result. So here, there were so many measures of performance that you could have tried, also so many ways that you could have measured diversity, and what she was able to find was a company which had delivered a positive result. Now here, the data mining was not done by Xingyi,
你以多种不同的方式运行数据，直到你得到一个积极的结果。在这里，有太多的绩效衡量标准你可以尝试，也有太多的方式你可以衡量多样性，而她能够找到的是一家得出了积极结果的公司。现在在这里，数据挖掘不是欣怡做的，
it was done by the company, but why might the company have wanted to get a positive result? Because the idea that diverse companies perform better, that's something that people want to be true. If indeed you deliver the result, you might be picked up and indeed their paper was picked up indeed by Xinyi and that led to positive publicity for that organization. Now I just want to clarify Alex that you're not saying that you think CEOs should get exorbitant payouts in excess of their workers or that diversity is a bad thing. You're just saying we need to trust the evidence as it comes in and report it accurately.
是那家公司做的，但为什么那家公司会想要得到一个积极的结果？因为多样化的公司表现更好的想法，是人们想要相信的事情。如果确实得出了结果，你可能会被选中，事实上他们的论文确实被欣怡选中了，这为该组织带来了积极的宣传。现在我只是想澄清一下，亚历克斯，你并不是说你认为首席执行官应该获得超过其员工的过高报酬，或者多样性是一件坏事。你只是说我们需要相信证据，并准确地报告它。
Absolutely and this is irrespective of your personal views on the topic. So personally, I believe that diversity is important. It's an important thing as an ethnic minority. It's something which is dear to me. But I believe that as a scientist, you should be like an expert witness in a criminal trial. Your role as a scientist is to state the evidence, just like your role as a witness
绝对是这样，这与你对该主题的个人观点无关。所以就我个人而言，我相信多样性很重要。作为一个少数族裔，这是一件重要的事情。这是我珍视的事情。但我认为作为一名科学家，你应该像刑事审判中的专家证人一样。你作为科学家的角色是陈述证据，就像你作为证人的角色
is to state the evidence clearly irrespective of your views of the issue. I want to talk about another driver of misinformation. Tell me the story of a woman named Belle Gibson. Belle Gibson was a young Australian. She had cancer and this cancer was terminal. She had tried radiotherapy and chemotherapy and none of that worked. So instead she tried clean eating and she was blogging about her journey and she made a miraculous recovery. She was cured from her cancer. And this story went viral. It was shared it could have reached millions and it encouraged other people to shun traditional medicine, chemotherapy and radiotherapy, for diet and exercise.
是清楚地陈述证据，无论你对该问题的看法如何。我想谈谈错误信息的另一个驱动因素。告诉我一个叫贝尔·吉布森的女人的故事。贝尔·吉布森是一位年轻的澳大利亚人。她患有癌症，而且是晚期。她尝试过放疗和化疗，但都没有用。所以她尝试了纯净饮食，并在博客上记录了她的旅程，她奇迹般地康复了。她从癌症中治愈了。这个故事疯传。它被分享，可能触及了数百万人，并鼓励其他人放弃传统医学、化疗和放疗，转而选择饮食和锻炼。
She got a book deal and this book deal was with Penguin Australia to have a cookbook showing what she did in order to cure herself from cancer. She also launched a healthy eating app called The Whole Pantry with recipes which were apparently curative of some of the most serious diseases. I mean, this is a fairy tale story, Alex. So someone has cancer, they cure themselves with cancer, they become a bestselling author, a successful entrepreneur. An amazing story, Alex. Is there any problem with it? Yes, there's one problem and sadly a big problem. She never had cancer.
她获得了一份图书合同，这份合同是与企鹅澳大利亚分公司签订的，要出一本食谱，展示她为了治愈癌症所做的事情。她还推出了一个名为“整个食品储藏室”的健康饮食应用程序，其中的食谱显然可以治愈一些最严重的疾病。我的意思是，这是一个童话故事，亚历克斯。所以有人得了癌症，他们治愈了癌症，他们成为了畅销书作家，成功的企业家。一个惊人的故事，亚历克斯。它有什么问题吗？是的，有一个问题，而且遗憾的是一个大问题。她从来没有得过癌症。
So this was a lie people shared a story without ever checking whether it was true. Some of the story is also about us, isn't it, Alex, which is that we wanted to believe that story, that story was appealing to us. Part of the reason she became a successful author and entrepreneur is because the story she was telling was a story that we actually wanted to hear. Absolutely. This was another example of confirmation bias. So why did we want to believe Belle's story?
所以这是一个谎言，人们在没有核实它是否真实的情况下就分享了一个故事。有些故事也是关于我们自己的，不是吗，亚历克斯，那就是我们想要相信那个故事，那个故事对我们很有吸引力。她成为成功作家和企业家的部分原因是，她讲述的故事是我们实际上想听到的故事。绝对是这样。这是确认偏误的另一个例子。那么我们为什么想相信贝尔的故事呢？
Because what it suggested is that you can achieve anything you want to, you can defeat even cancer if you just put your mind to it. And this is what we tell our kids, we tell them you can do anything you put your mind to. And so the idea that she was shunning traditional medicine, these were the chemicals that you get injected with if you're doing curing therapy,
因为它暗示你可以实现你想要的任何事情，只要你下定决心，你甚至可以战胜癌症。这就是我们告诉孩子们的，我们告诉他们，只要你下定决心，你就能做任何事情。所以她放弃传统医学的想法，这些是你如果进行治疗就会被注射的化学物质，
for something like clean eating. And that again, accords with our worldview that something natural is better than the medicines of a giant corporation. So it sort of made sense to us. And she was inspiring. And so she inspired everybody that even if you were at a death store, you could have a second chance of life. We love those underdog stories. They are in the fairy tales we learn as kids, we read as kids, but this was apparently not a fairy tale. This was somebody who we could see, looked really well and was eating healthily.
转而选择纯净饮食。这再次符合我们的世界观，即天然的东西比大公司的药物更好。所以它对我们来说很有意义。而且她很鼓舞人心。所以她激励了每个人，即使你处于死亡边缘，你也可以有第二次生命的机会。我们喜欢那些弱者的故事。它们存在于我们小时候学习、阅读的童话故事中，但这显然不是童话。这是一个我们可以看到、看起来真的很健康并且吃得很健康的人。
So you say that the Bella Gibson story is an example of something called the narrative fallacy. What is the narrative fallacy here, Alex? The narrative fallacy is to see some events and believe that there is a link between the two, is that we can weave in a narrative which supports our view of the world. So if we see, claim that she had cancer, now claim that she didn't have cancer anymore, was cured, and we can see that she was clean eating, we weave in the explanation that we want, which is the clean eating cured her cancer. Now there's alternative explanations to this, and an alternative explanation could be that she lied because nobody had ever checked a claim of cancer, or even if she was cured,
所以你说贝尔·吉布森的故事是所谓的叙事谬误的一个例子。这里的叙事谬误是什么，亚历克斯？叙事谬误是看到一些事件并相信两者之间存在联系，是我们能够编织一个支持我们世界观的叙事。所以如果我们看到，声称她患有癌症，现在声称她不再患有癌症，被治愈了，我们可以看到她一直在进行纯净饮食，我们编织了我们想要的解释，即纯净饮食治愈了她的癌症。现在对此有替代解释，一个替代解释可能是她撒谎了，因为从来没有人核实过癌症的声明，或者即使她被治愈了，
it could have been that she did other things to have been cured or maybe she didn't lie but she was misdiagnosed in the first place but those narratives don't feel so good to us so we latch on to the one narrative that we like just going back to the criminal trial example it would be like the police latching on to one particular suspect because of some particular prejudice and ignoring the alternative suspects. You know, we've talked elsewhere on the show about how the brain is a sense-making machine and we are in some ways evolutionarily wired to draw connections and see patterns and seek
可能是她做了其他事情才被治愈，或者也许她没有撒谎，但她一开始就被误诊了，但这些叙事对我们来说感觉不太好，所以我们抓住了我们喜欢的那个叙事。回到刑事审判的例子，就像警察因为某种特定的偏见而抓住一个特定的嫌疑人，而忽略了其他嫌疑人一样。你知道，我们在节目中其他地方谈到过大脑是如何成为一个意义构建机器的，我们在某种程度上在进化上被设定为建立联系、观察模式并寻求
out explanations. So we may have all of the world's information at our fingertips, but in some ways we still have the same brain to make sense of it all. So Daniel Kahneman in his book Thinking Fast and Slow said there are two systems. There's the system two, which is rational. It knows to check the facts before ditching chemotherapy, check that this person actually did have cancer and was cured from clean eating. But there's the system one, which is the part of the brain that is activated by a fight or flight response. And that is one where we believe what we want to be true and we're not acting in a discerning way. So even really smart people who most of the time can activate
解释。所以我们可能触手可及拥有世界上所有的信息，但在某种程度上，我们仍然拥有同样的大脑来理解这一切。所以丹尼尔·卡尼曼在他的书《思考，快与慢》中说有两个系统。一个是系统二，它是理性的。它知道在放弃化疗之前要核实事实，核实这个人是否真的患有癌症并从纯净饮食中治愈。但有一个系统一，它是大脑中被战斗或逃跑反应激活的部分。那是我们相信我们想要相信的东西，而且我们没有以敏锐的方式行事。所以即使是非常聪明的人，大多数时候都能激活
their system too, and this is a really well-functioning system, when indeed our emotions take over, we forget basic things like correlation is not causation, check the facts, or are there other narratives than the one that we're trying to assign? So we talked earlier about how, you know, the evidence can sometimes be unreliable because researchers and policymakers can pick and choose their findings. But even when the data holds up, we sometimes can use data to make claims that are not necessarily supported by the data. You have a story about this. Tell me about the day that your son Casper was born and everything you had learned about raising a newborn child. Yeah, so this was an amazing day as anybody who's experienced the birth of a child will know and so we had huge positive
他们的系统二，这是一个功能非常良好的系统，但当我们的情绪接管时，我们忘记了基本的事情，比如相关性不是因果关系，核实事实，或者是否有比我们试图分配的叙事之外的其他叙事？所以我们之前谈到过，你知道，证据有时可能是不可靠的，因为研究人员和政策制定者可以挑选他们的发现。但即使数据成立，我们有时也可以使用数据来提出不一定被数据支持的说法。你有一个关于这个的故事。告诉我你儿子卡斯珀出生的那天，以及你所学到的关于抚养新生儿的一切。是的，这是令人惊奇的一天，正如任何经历过孩子出生的人所知道的那样，所以我们有巨大的积极
emotions but then we realized we need to look after this little guy and one of the big questions is what to feed him and And my wife and I thought, well, this is a no-brainer. We had taken a national trial birth trust parenting course and the NCT is extremely well respected within the UK. And they talked about many things such as changing nappies, what to do if the baby is sick, but there were two classes devoted to breastfeeding. And while much of this was on how to breastfeed, it started with why breastfeed. The idea being that breastfeeding is tough, so if they convinced us of the benefits, then even if we were bleary-eyed and weary and wanted to reach for the rattle, we wouldn't because of the benefits. And so what they gave was a message which was also reinforced
情绪，但随后我们意识到我们需要照顾这个小家伙，最大的问题之一是喂他什么。我和我妻子想，好吧，这不用动脑筋。我们参加了一个国家试验生育信托育儿课程，NCT在英国非常受人尊敬。他们谈论了很多事情，比如换尿布，如果婴儿生病了该怎么办，但有两节课专门讨论母乳喂养。虽然其中大部分是关于如何母乳喂养，但它始于为什么要母乳喂养。其想法是母乳喂养很艰难，所以如果他们说服了我们其好处，那么即使我们睡眼惺忪、疲惫不堪，想要伸手去拿拨浪鼓，我们也不会，因为其好处。所以他们给出的信息也得到了
by the World Health Organization which said that you should exclusively breastfeed at least for the first six months, no water, no formula, no other fluids. And so why did they give this advice? Because of a strong correlation based on data. And what was that correlation? Babies who were breastfed exclusively had better outcomes later in life. This could be mental outcomes such as child IQ, that could be physical outcomes as well, such as reduction in allergies and other potential ailments. So in some ways the data linking breastfeeding with
世界卫生组织的强化，该组织表示你应该至少在前六个月进行纯母乳喂养，不喝水，不喝配方奶，不喝其他液体。那么他们为什么要给出这个建议呢？因为基于数据的强相关性。那个相关性是什么？纯母乳喂养的婴儿在以后的生活中会有更好的结果。这可能是心理结果，比如儿童智商，也可能是身体结果，比如减少过敏和其他潜在疾病。所以从某种程度上说，将母乳喂养与
good outcomes in life is truly voluminous. I mean, they're probably warehouses of studies now that show the connection between these two things. But in the early days of your son's life, your doctors recommended feeding your child newborn formula along with breast milk. What was the reasoning here? Yeah, so the obstetrician said that in Casper's case,
生活中好的结果联系起来的数据确实非常庞大。我的意思是，现在可能已经有仓库的研究表明这两者之间的联系。但在你儿子生命的早期，你的医生建议给你的孩子喂新生儿配方奶和母乳。这里的推理是什么？是的，产科医生说在卡斯珀的情况下，
because he was born a little bit underweight, that it was important to top him up with formula. And also because he was born a little bit early, there was the risk of jaundice. So what is this? This is when there's lots of bilirubin in the system, and bilirubin is something which, if it accumulates, can cause jaundice.
因为他出生时体重有点轻，所以给他补充配方奶很重要。而且因为他出生得有点早，有黄疸的风险。那么这是什么？这是当系统中有很多胆红素时，而胆红素是如果积累起来，会导致黄疸的东西。
And in babies born early, this is particularly prevalent. And so the advantage of putting formula in is that that would flush out the bilirubin and reduce the risk of jaundice. So to us, it was not as black and white as the World Health Organization or the NCT course was suggesting. So what did you do? On the one hand, you have these warehouses of data telling you that breastfeeding is the only way to go. And your doctor is basically saying, you know, breastfeeding and formula. What did you do? So I did my own research and I thought this is my job as an academic. If I do this in my day job,
在早产儿中，这种情况特别普遍。所以加入配方奶的好处是，那会冲走胆红素并降低黄疸的风险。所以对我们来说，它不像世界卫生组织或NCT课程所暗示的那样非黑即白。所以你做了什么？一方面，你有这些仓库的数据告诉你母乳喂养是唯一的出路。而你的医生基本上说，你知道，母乳喂养和配方奶。你做了什么？所以我做了我自己的研究，我想这是我作为学者的工作。如果我在日常工作中这样做，
shouldn't I also do this research in something as important as my child's well-being? So I did some Google searches myself. So I didn't just take at face value the studies quoted by the NCT, because as you're mentioning, if you have a particular viewpoint, you can find the study to support that viewpoint. But if I Google breastfeeding IQ, I found lots of studies which also reinforced the result
难道我不应该在像孩子健康这样重要的事情上也做同样的研究吗？所以我自己做了一些谷歌搜索。我没有照单全收NCT引用的研究，因为正如你所提到的，如果你有特定的观点，你总能找到支持该观点的研究。但如果我搜索“母乳喂养与智商”，我发现许多研究也强化了NCT课程所暗示的结果。
that the NCT course had suggested. But then when I clicked on those particular studies, it actually gave a more nuanced picture. So what they found is that if you did a simple comparison of breastfed versus bottle-fed kids, then there was a difference in IQ and other outcomes. But what some studies also did was they realised that you needed to make adjustments. Why? Because breastfed and bottle-fed babies differ according to many other dimensions, not just the feeding method. So breastfeeding is really tough. It can be difficult without family support. So maybe it was babies with a better home life, a superior home environment, that were breastfed.
但当我点击那些特定的研究时，它们实际上提供了更细致的图景。他们发现，如果对母乳喂养和奶瓶喂养的孩子进行简单的比较，智商和其他结果确实存在差异。但一些研究也意识到，你需要进行调整。为什么？因为母乳喂养和奶瓶喂养的婴儿在许多其他维度上存在差异，不仅仅是喂养方式。母乳喂养真的很辛苦，如果没有家庭支持，可能会很困难。所以，也许是那些拥有更好家庭生活、更优越家庭环境的婴儿才被母乳喂养。
And it could be that home environment led to the better outcomes, not the feeding methodology. Also, older mothers tended to breastfeed. It could be the mother's more educated. There were other things such as the mother who was less likely to smoke is also more likely to breastfeed. And it could be all of those factors which were behind the child outcomes not the feeding method. And in fact when these studies controlled for those other factors what that means is when they stripped out the influence of those other factors on IQ and the other outcomes the link between breastfeeding and IQ was pretty much zero. So again I don't think what I'm hearing you saying is that breastfeeding is ineffective
而且可能是家庭环境导致了更好的结果，而不是喂养方式。此外，年龄较大的母亲倾向于母乳喂养。母亲可能受教育程度更高。还有其他因素，比如不太可能吸烟的母亲也更有可能进行母乳喂养。可能正是所有这些因素在背后影响了孩子的结果，而不是喂养方式。事实上，当这些研究控制了这些其他因素时，这意味着当它们剥离了这些因素对智商和其他结果的影响后，母乳喂养与智商之间的联系几乎为零。所以，我并不认为你是在说母乳喂养无效
or useless. You're basically saying that black and white thinking about breastfeeding might be the problem here. That is correct. And so why is this such an important issue is that many women feel guilt tripped into only breastfeeding and they feel guilty if they are considering something else. And this is problematic because it means that if they're exhausted then they are still trying to breastfeed and that exhaustion can actually be bad not just for the mother but also for the child's
或毫无用处。你基本上是在说，关于母乳喂养的非黑即白的思维方式可能才是问题所在。没错。那么，为什么这是一个如此重要的问题呢？因为许多女性感到被负罪感所困，认为必须纯母乳喂养，如果她们考虑其他方式就会感到内疚。这很有问题，因为这意味着如果她们精疲力竭，她们仍然在尝试母乳喂养，而这种疲惫不仅对母亲有害，对孩子的
development. It also means that as a father you can't get as involved in feeding and feeding is one way to bond with your child and so the message which is often perpetrated, which is never do anything other than breastfeeding is where we're a careful look at the data is really important. The world makes it easy for us to find facts that confirm our pre-existing beliefs and seek out stories that tell us our values and our hearts are in the right place.
发育也可能有害。这也意味着作为父亲，你无法更多地参与喂养，而喂养是与孩子建立联系的一种方式。因此，那种经常被传播的“除了母乳喂养外什么都不要做”的信息，正是我们需要仔细审视数据的地方。这个世界让我们很容易找到证实我们既有信念的事实，并寻找那些告诉我们价值观和内心是正确的故事。
So how can we know whether to trust what we read, watch and hear? When we come back, strategies for sifting through the information coming at us every day and fighting back against falsehoods and bad actors. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When we think of misinformation, we think of politicians making outlandish claims, or self-proclaimed experts selling snake oil.
那么，我们如何知道该相信我们所读、所看和所听的内容呢？回来后，我们将探讨筛选每天涌向我们的信息并反击虚假信息和不良行为者的策略。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当我们想到错误信息时，我们会想到政客们发表离谱的言论，或者自封的专家兜售江湖骗术。
But in reality, misinformation isn't always obvious and not easily avoidable. Much of the time the things we fall for are shaped by our own psychological needs and biases. Economist Alex Edmonds is the author of the book May Contain Lies, How Stories, Statistics and Studies Exploit Our Biases and What We Can Do About It. Alex has a powerful example of misinformation in his own life. He once watched an inspiring talk given by an acrobat with the entertainment company Cirque du Soleil.
但实际上，错误信息并不总是显而易见的，也不容易避免。很多时候，我们所相信的东西是由我们自己的心理需求和偏见所塑造的。经济学家亚历克斯·埃德蒙兹是《可能包含谎言：故事、统计数据和研究如何利用我们的偏见以及我们能做些什么》一书的作者。亚历克斯在他自己的生活中有一个关于错误信息的有力例子。他曾经看过一位来自太阳马戏团的杂技演员所做的鼓舞人心的演讲。
So what this talk was about was the idea of the 10,000 hours rule. So people wondered how this guy James was so able to perform amazing acrobatics. And he said, this was not due to any hidden gene or special innate talent, but just hours and hours of deliberate practice. So what the acrobat was following is what's known as the 10,000 hours rule, which was popularized by the famous author Malcolm Gladwell in his book Outliers. The idea was you could
这次演讲的主题是“一万小时定律”。人们好奇这个叫詹姆斯的人是如何能够表演惊人的杂技的。他说，这并不是因为什么隐藏的基因或特殊的天赋，而仅仅是数小时又数小时的刻意练习。所以这位杂技演员遵循的是所谓的“一万小时定律”，该定律由著名作家马尔科姆·格拉德威尔在他的书《异类》中推广。这个想法是，你可以在
be successful in a number of domains if you put in 10,000 hours of deliberate effort. Why was this idea appealing to you, Alex? Because this confirmed everything I thought to be true. So you're told when you're young, practice makes perfect, you can do anything you put your mind to, and also it's empowering. This suggests that you're not a slave to genetics. If you want anything in life, you can get it as long as you're willing to put in the effort. And it also accords with our views of good work ethic. We like to believe that the people who succeed are not just given some magic powers, but they really had to work in order to get where they were. Now, besides being an economist, I understand you're also an avid tennis player, and you tried
许多领域取得成功，只要你投入一万小时的刻意努力。亚历克斯，为什么这个想法对你有吸引力？因为它证实了我认为正确的一切。所以你年轻时被告知，熟能生巧，只要你下定决心，什么都能做到，而且这很赋能。这表明你不是基因的奴隶。如果你想要生活中的任何东西，只要你愿意付出努力，你就能得到它。这也符合我们对良好职业道德的看法。我们喜欢相信那些成功的人不仅仅是被赋予了某种魔法，而是他们确实通过努力才达到了现在的地位。现在，除了作为一名经济学家，我了解到你还是一位狂热的网球爱好者，你尝试
to imbibe the 10,000-hour rule in improving your tennis game. Tell me what you did. Yeah, so I used, I love to play tennis and still do, and so I played quite a lot of tennis during my time at MIT when I was a PhD student with a couple of friends. And one guy called Florian Ederer, he always wanted to play a game against me. He always wanted to keep score. But to me, I already had enough stress doing my PhD. I didn't want to add extra stress with this game. And also Florian Ederer is F Ederer,
将一万小时定律应用到提高你的网球水平上。告诉我你做了什么。是的，我喜欢打网球，现在依然喜欢。我在麻省理工学院读博士期间，和几个朋友打了很多网球。有一个叫弗洛里安·埃德勒的人，他总是想和我比赛。他总是想记分。但对我来说，读博士已经够有压力了，我不想再因为比赛增加额外的压力。而且弗洛里安·埃德勒的名字是F Ederer，
so I was intimidated by keeping score against somebody whose name was effectively Federer. But what the 10,000 hours rule suggested is all that mattered was the hours that you put in. So it didn't matter whether you were playing a game or knocking the ball around. So I thought let me just knock the ball around because that is just fun and I'm getting my hours in. I'm moving myself towards the magic number. Alex didn't just follow the 10,000 hours rule, he preached it to others. So I had actually used this 10,000 hours rule in my class when I was an assistant professor at Wharton.
所以我对和一个名字实际上是“费德勒”的人记分感到畏惧。但一万小时定律暗示，唯一重要的是你投入的时间。所以，无论你是打比赛还是随便打打球都无所谓。所以我心想，我就随便打打球吧，因为那很有趣，而且我正在积累我的时间。我正在向那个神奇的数字迈进。亚历克斯不仅遵循了一万小时定律，他还向别人宣扬它。所以，当我在沃顿商学院担任助理教授时，我实际上在课堂上使用过这个一万小时定律。
I typically gave as my final lecture some advice about general life, similar to a last lecture that you sometimes see professors give, and the 10,000 hours rule was often featured, and when I talked about this I get knowing nods as if this was a truth universally acknowledged. A few years later, Alex moved to London. He began a part-time position at another college where he planned a lecture on the growth mindset. This is the idea that you can achieve much more when you don't believe your abilities are limited. With hard work and dedication,
我通常会在最后一节课上给出一些关于一般生活的建议，类似于你有时看到教授们做的“最后一课”，一万小时定律经常被提及。当我谈到这一点时，我会得到赞许的点头，仿佛这是一个普遍公认的真理。几年后，亚历克斯搬到了伦敦。他在另一所学院开始了一份兼职工作，在那里他计划讲授“成长型思维”。这个想法是，当你不再认为自己的能力是有限的时候，你可以取得更大的成就。通过努力工作和奉献，
you can accomplish more than you ever thought possible. The 10,000 hours rule was to take center stage in the lecture, so Alex figured he should go back and read the original claim carefully. He found a couple of things that worried him. So the first was I had actually learned an incorrect version of the rule. So Malcolm Gladwell had never claimed that 10,000 hours leads to success, that would suggest that 10,000 hours was sufficient for success. Instead, he claimed that 10,000 hours was necessary for success. What is the difference? So Gladwell suggests that you might need talent, but talent alone is not going to get you there.
你可以完成比你想象中更多的成就。一万小时定律将在讲座中占据中心位置，所以亚历克斯想他应该回去仔细阅读最初的声明。他发现了一些让他担心的事情。首先，我实际上学到了一个错误版本的定律。马尔科姆·格拉德威尔从未声称一万小时会导致成功，那会暗示一万小时是成功的充分条件。相反，他声称一万小时是成功的必要条件。有什么区别？格拉德威尔暗示你可能需要天赋，但仅有天赋是无法让你成功的。
You need talent plus hard work. But the second issue is Gladwell as far from blameless either, because even his version of the rule was not backed up by underlying data. So the main paper that he cites in support of his rule, he calls it Exhibit A in the book, is a paper by Anders Eriksson, a psychologist, which looks at violinists. So that should already ring a bell. Why, violinist is one specific activity and yet this rule apparently applied to becoming an acrobat, being a chess player, being a neurosurgeon, but those all quite different contexts. But
你需要天赋加上努力工作。但第二个问题是，格拉德威尔也远非无可指责，因为即使是他版本的定律也没有得到底层数据的支持。所以他引用的支持该定律的主要论文，他在书中称之为“证据A”，是心理学家安德斯·埃里克森关于小提琴手的一篇论文。这应该已经敲响了警钟。为什么？小提琴手是一项特定的活动，然而这个定律显然适用于成为杂技演员、国际象棋棋手、神经外科医生，但这些都是完全不同的背景。但
let's take that aside. What did this violin study look at? It looked at violin students at the Berlin Academy of Music, it had the teachers classify them according to whether they thought they were good or not. So number one, this never actually measured success. So Malcolm Gladwell's book is about the story of success. Here this was just teachers' perceptions of whether they would be good, and so that again suggests there could be alternative theories. If indeed you know that the student is practicing a lot, you're much more likely to say that they are successful, right? Because your violin ability is not something easily measurable, like a half marathon time.
让我们把这一点放在一边。这项小提琴研究考察了什么？它考察了柏林音乐学院的小提琴学生，让老师根据他们是否认为学生优秀来进行分类。所以第一，这从未真正衡量过成功。所以马尔科姆·格拉德威尔的书是关于成功的故事。这里这只是老师们对他们是否会成功的看法，所以这再次表明可能存在其他理论。如果你确实知道学生练习了很多，你更有可能说他们是成功的，对吧？因为你的小提琴能力不是像半程马拉松时间那样容易衡量的。
So if you know somebody's working hard, you probably think they're doing better. And there were more problems with the study. It asked students how many hours they had practiced from age five onwards. Some of the students were in their 20s at the time of the study. Another issue is that how would you know how long you practiced? Could you remember 18 years ago when you were age five how much you practiced back then? You probably couldn't. And again this could be skewing things. Why? Because if you know you're doing really well right now, you're a great violinist, you think I
所以如果你知道某人工作努力，你可能会认为他们做得更好。这项研究还有更多问题。它询问学生从五岁起练习了多少小时。研究时，一些学生已经二十多岁了。另一个问题是，你怎么知道你练习了多久？你能记得18年前你五岁时练习了多少吗？你可能记不住。这再次可能扭曲了事情。为什么？因为如果你知道你现在做得很好，你是一位出色的小提琴手，你会认为我
must have practiced. And if you're not doing so well, then you think, well, I can't have practiced that hard. How you're doing right now affects your reports of your practice rather than the practice affecting whether you're successful. And finally, and this is particularly pertinent for me, the study by Erickson never said it's just about the quantity of hours. He also highlighted the quality. So what matters is perhaps deliberate practice guided by a coach which is difficult and uncomfortable, not just jam sessions. And my hitting around with Florian Edera without keeping score, that was the equivalent of just jamming
一定练习过。如果你做得不是那么好，那么你会想，好吧，我不可能练习得那么努力。你现在的表现影响了你对练习的报告，而不是练习影响了你是否成功。最后，这一点对我特别重要，埃里克森的研究从未说这仅仅是关于小时的数量。他还强调了质量。所以重要的可能是由教练指导的、困难且不舒服的刻意练习，而不仅仅是即兴演奏。我和弗洛里安·埃德勒不记分地随便打球，那相当于只是随便
around, whereas keeping score and playing a game, that was what was going to get me better. You know, Alex, I think one thing the story tells me is that there are ideas and concepts that get into the stream of public life and once they are there, they take on a life of their own. So even if Anders Eriksson and Malcolm Gladwell come along to say, you know, that is not really what I said, that is not really what I meant, the sheer inertia of the collective belief now becomes almost impossible to stop.
玩玩，而记分并进行比赛，那才是让我进步的方法。你知道，亚历克斯，我认为这个故事告诉我的事情之一是，有些想法和概念进入了公共生活的洪流，一旦它们在那里，它们就有了自己的生命。所以即使安德斯·埃里克森和马尔科姆·格拉德威尔出来说，你知道，那不是我真正说的，那不是我真正意思，集体信念的纯粹惯性现在变得几乎无法阻止。
So I think there's a phrase that the lies are spread halfway around the world before the truth has put the shoes on and this is what we see in terms of misinformation. Let's talk about some ways in which we can combat these problems. You recommend a few exercises that can help all of us and one of them is called consider the opposite. What is the consider the opposite exercise, Alex? So the consider the opposite idea is to try to get around this problem of confirmation
所以我认为有一句名言，谎言在真相穿上鞋子之前就已经传遍了半个世界，这就是我们在错误信息方面所看到的。让我们谈谈我们可以对抗这些问题的一些方法。你推荐了一些可以帮助我们所有人的练习，其中一个叫做“考虑相反面”。什么是“考虑相反面”练习，亚历克斯？所以“考虑相反面”的想法是试图绕过这个确认
bias. So again, what is confirmation bias? We latch on to something uncritically if it confirms what we want to be true, and we reject something out of hand if we don't want it to be true. So why is this interesting? Because what it means is that we are able to show discernment. If there's a study that we don't like, we can come up with a whole host of reasons for why it's unreliable. And so what I'm doing with the consider the opposite rule is to try to activate the discernment that we already have and we use selectively for studies that we don't like, but now apply it to studies that we do like. So maybe just by giving an example, this will come to life. So let's say I want an excuse after finishing
偏见的问题。所以再次重申，什么是确认偏见？如果某事证实了我们想要相信的东西，我们就盲目地接受它；如果某事是我们不想相信的，我们就直接拒绝它。那么为什么这很有趣呢？因为它意味着我们有能力表现出辨别力。如果有一项我们不喜欢的研究，我们可以找出许多理由说明它为什么不可靠。所以我用“考虑相反面”规则所做的是，试图激活我们已经拥有并选择性地用于我们不喜欢的那些研究的辨别力，但现在将其应用于我们喜欢的那些研究。所以也许举个例子，这就会变得生动起来。假设在结束
this podcast to drink loads of red wine. So I might look up on Google why red wine is good for your health and I find studies that people who drink red wine live longer. But consider the opposite. We'll ask, what if I found the opposite result? People who drink red wine live shorter. How would I try to attack that result? I might say, well, maybe people who drink red wine are poor. They can't afford champagne, they have to drink red wine instead, and it's that poverty which leads to a shorter life, not the red wine. But now I've alerted myself to the alternative explanation of income being the driver, then I should ask is this the driver of the result that I do want? Again red wine is correlated with longer life, is it the case that the people who can afford red wine are richer and it's their wealth that leads
这个播客后，我想找个借口喝大量的红酒。所以我可能会在谷歌上搜索为什么红酒对你的健康有好处，我发现了一些研究说喝红酒的人寿命更长。但考虑相反面。我会问，如果我发现了相反的结果呢？喝红酒的人寿命更短。我会如何尝试攻击那个结果？我可能会说，好吧，也许喝红酒的人很穷。他们买不起香槟，他们不得不喝红酒，正是那种贫困导致了寿命缩短，而不是红酒。但现在我已经提醒自己注意收入是驱动因素的另一种解释，那么我应该问，这是我想要的结果的驱动因素吗？同样，红酒与长寿相关，是否是因为买得起红酒的人更富有，是他们的财富导致了
to the longer life? So the idea of considering the opposite is to trigger the discernment that we exercise selectively and make sure it's now universal. One of the other techniques that you recommend that can help us combat misinformation and confirmation bias is curiosity. And perhaps that's not a technique as much as an orientation, but talk about how curiosity can be a defense against our own biases. Yeah, so this is also interesting because often we think that just general knowledge is perhaps a way to avoid misinformation because the smarter we are, the more able we are to separate the weak from the chaff. But unfortunately, this is not the case. There are some studies
更长的寿命？所以“考虑相反面”的想法是触发我们选择性行使的辨别力，并确保它现在是普遍的。你推荐的另一种可以帮助我们对抗错误信息和确认偏见的技巧是好奇心。也许那与其说是一种技巧，不如说是一种导向，但谈谈好奇心如何成为对抗我们自身偏见的防御手段。是的，这也很有趣，因为我们经常认为仅仅是一般的知识也许是避免错误信息的一种方式，因为我们越聪明，我们就越有能力将弱点与精华分开。但不幸的是，事实并非如此。有一些研究
which actually suggest that knowledge makes things worse because the more sophisticated we are, the more intelligent we are, the easier it is for us to slam evidence we don't like and to come up with reasons for why we don't want to believe it. But again, we deploy this only selectively. We don't deploy this to the evidence that we do like. So even if knowledge doesn't work, well actually curiosity does. So there was a study which looked at the effect of knowledge, found it had no effect, but curiosity did have an effect. So these researchers found that the more curious you were, the more balanced you were on issues such as climate change.
实际上表明知识让事情变得更糟，因为我们越复杂，我们越聪明，我们就越容易抨击我们不喜欢的证据，并找出我们不想相信它的理由。但同样，我们只选择性地部署这一点。我们不会将其部署到我们喜欢的证据上。所以即使知识不起作用，实际上好奇心确实起作用。所以有一项研究考察了知识的影响，发现它没有影响，但好奇心确实有影响。所以这些研究人员发现，你越好奇，你在气候变化等问题上就越平衡。
In particular, your views on climate change were less linked to your political affiliation. So you were going based on the evidence, not based on your identity. You also recommend that people ask themselves questions, questions like, do I want this conclusion to be true? Or is this conclusion extreme? Or does this conclusion imply universality?
特别是，你对气候变化的观点与你的政治倾向的联系较少。所以你是基于证据，而不是基于你的身份。你还建议人们问自己问题，比如，我希望这个结论是真的吗？或者这个结论是否极端？或者这个结论是否暗示了普遍性？
And I guess all these questions are ways of basically asking people to slow down the freight train of their conclusions, to to basically say is there an alternative explanation that I'm not seeing. Absolutely again it's just to exercise discernment which we already do sometimes and selectively but let's try to do this all the time including and in particular for things that we do want to be true. Hmm you know one thing that strikes me here Alex is that we do want to be true. You know, one thing that strikes me here, Alex, is that we often feel that misinformation
我想所有这些问题基本上都是要求人们减慢他们结论的货运列车，基本上是问有没有我没看到的另一种解释。绝对的，再次重申，这只是为了行使我们有时会选择性行使的辨别力，但让我们尝试一直这样做，包括并且特别是在我们确实希望是真的事情上。嗯，你知道，亚历克斯，这里有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是我们确实希望它是真的。你知道，亚历克斯，这里有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是我们经常觉得错误信息
is the province of our enemies and our opponents. So we all find it easy to see our opponents as being misled by false information, our political opponents in particular. We imagine that they are the source of false information. But one pattern in our conversation that I'm gleaning is that one of the greatest sources of our vulnerability is in fact not our enemies, but our friends. We're skeptical when our enemies and opponents talk. We want to believe our friends. We do. And we also
是我们敌人和对手的领域。所以我们都觉得很容易看到我们的对手被错误信息误导，特别是我们的政治对手。我们想象他们是错误信息来源。但在我们的谈话中，我收集到的一个模式是，我们最大的脆弱性来源之一实际上不是我们的敌人，而是我们的朋友。当我们的敌人和对手说话时，我们持怀疑态度。我们想相信我们的朋友。我们确实想。而且我们也
want to believe ourselves. So an even greater enemy than our friends is perhaps ourselves, because it means that we are latching on to particular types of information. And while you might think well this is a depressing conclusion, is that our friends and ourselves are the cause, it's actually an uplifting conclusion because it means that the solutions are within ourselves. Because if the source of misinformation was the enemy, they're gonna keep producing misinformation, we can't do anything about it. But if indeed the problem is the way that we respond to information is based on our biases, we latch onto what we want to be true, we ignore what we don't, just by changing this,
想相信我们自己。所以比我们的朋友更大的敌人也许是我们自己，因为这意味着我们正在抓住特定类型的信息。虽然你可能会想，这是一个令人沮丧的结论，即我们的朋友和我们自己是原因，但这实际上是一个令人振奋的结论，因为它意味着解决方案就在我们自己身上。因为如果错误信息的来源是敌人，他们会继续制造错误信息，我们对此无能为力。但如果问题确实是我们对信息的反应方式是基于我们的偏见，我们抓住我们想要是真的东西，忽略我们不想要的，只要改变这一点，
using strategies such as consider the opposite, that will allow us to be able to combat the misinformation that we see. Alex Edmonds is the author of the book, May Contain Lies, How Stories, Statistics and Studies Exploit Our Biases and What We Can Do About It. Alex, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks Shankar, really enjoyed the conversation. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul,
使用诸如“考虑相反面”之类的策略，这将使我们能够对抗我们所看到的错误信息。亚历克斯·埃德蒙兹是《可能包含谎言：故事、统计数据和研究如何利用我们的偏见以及我们能做些什么》一书的作者。亚历克斯，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢尚卡尔，非常享受这次谈话。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、
Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by Discover. Our story comes from Angela Zhao in Beijing. In 2020, when Angela was just 10 years old, she entered her first piano competition. She was excited, but right before it was her turn to perform,
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。今天我们以我们姐妹节目《我未被歌颂的英雄》中的一个故事结束。这个《我未被歌颂的英雄》片段由Discover为您呈现。我们的故事来自北京的安吉拉·赵。2020年，当安吉拉只有10岁时，她参加了她的第一次钢琴比赛。她很兴奋，但在轮到她表演之前，
she started to doubt herself. What if I played the wrong notes? What if I forgot the notes? What if I just messed up? Then, a competitor of mine made me confident. She was the person before me to perform on the stage. Before it was my turn to go onto the stage and perform my piece, she looked at me and smiled with thumb up. Her smile made the stage light lighter and warmer to me. She made me stop thinking too much and started to think that I can do that. Her smile made me think that the stage is just right for me and the piano is just right
她开始怀疑自己。如果我弹错了音符怎么办？如果我忘了音符怎么办？如果我搞砸了怎么办？然后，我的一位竞争对手让我有了信心。她是舞台上在我之前表演的人。在我轮到上台表演我的曲目之前，她看着我，竖起大拇指微笑着。她的微笑让舞台灯光对我来说更亮、更温暖。她让我停止想太多，开始认为我可以做到。她的微笑让我觉得舞台正适合我，钢琴也正适合
for me. Most importantly, that smile made me think that today I'm just right and I can perform on the stage. After my performance, I can see that she clapped for me and looked straight at me. As a competitor, she gave me respect and helped the shy girl to face the stage. That girl from that day, if you can hear this, I just want you to know
我。最重要的是，那个微笑让我觉得今天我表现得恰到好处，我可以在舞台上表演。表演结束后，我可以看到她为我鼓掌，并直视着我。作为一名竞争对手，她给了我尊重，并帮助这个害羞的女孩面对舞台。那天的那位女孩，如果你能听到这个，我只想让你知道
you changed the moment of my life and your kind smile remained in my memory. And I'll take that smile as a precious gift. Angela Zhao lives in Beijing, China. The piano you're hearing right now is Angela's performance in that very competition for which she won the silver award. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover.
你改变了我生命中的那一刻，你善良的微笑留在了我的记忆中。我会把那个微笑当作珍贵的礼物。安吉拉·赵住在中国的北京。你现在听到的钢琴声是安吉拉在那场比赛中的表演，她凭借那场表演赢得了银奖。《我未被歌颂的英雄》的这一片段由Discover为您呈现。
Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit this spirit in their communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself. Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. If you're an Android user, you can sign up at support.hiddenbrain.org. Those sites again are apple.co.hiddenbrain and support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Discover相信每个人都值得感到特别，并赞美那些在社区中展现这种精神的人。我自己也是一位长期的持卡会员。在discover.com/creditcard了解更多信息。如果你是安卓用户，你可以在support.hiddenbrain.org注册。这些网站再次是apple.co.hiddenbrain和support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。